we spent a lot of time yesterday talking
about the antonio brown fiasco in
pittsburgh and the story was advanced by
virtue of mike tomlin's end-of-season
press conference plenty of things were
said
several things not said that that are
strongly implied the bottom line is this
mike tomlin is not happy with antonio
brown and mike tomlin acknowledged that
brown went awol last week right now he
glossed over thursday i'm told he was a
no-show on thursday they enlisted him as
not practicing due to a knee injury they
should have listed him as not practicing
because we don't know where he is right
right but but tomlin acknowledged that
after friday when he told brown to go
get an mri there was no communication
from brown at any point after that until
sunday when his agent drew rosenhaus
called tomlin on game day and said
antonio is ready to play and tomlin said
sorry that ship has sailed he's not
playing i haven't heard from him since
friday so tomlin was was
he was measured
but it's clear that he's not happy and
he didn't he didn't huff and puff but
i'm getting the impression they're going
to blow antonio brown's house down well
i would think at some point yes they're
going to have a sit down and draw a line
in the sand and say
listen there's going to be consequences
if you cross this line anymore now i do
think mike tomlin is angry as hell he's
a great leader as you know i stick up
for mike tomlin i've been around him
he's a great communicator and i know
he's taken a lot of crap through this
whole thing and i think the point that
it's interesting first of all like we
talked about it yesterday you know i
talked to five different people
about this whole scenario and when went
down and you talked about thursday and
how that was glossed over i think it was
glossed over a little bit because there
was some communication on that day
because four out of the five people i
talked to said he wasn't there thursday
friday saturday where he told them his
need was sore and he was gonna get it
checked out so i think that's why it
gets glossed over a little bit because
they feel like there was some
communication there but the whole thing
is crazy for arguably the best player on
your team to go a wall the biggest game
of the year for that football team and
not be there and as i know it major
people within the organization calling
him reaching out and not being just
getting crickets you know that's unheard
of and you know it's a weird situation
when the agent has to call the coach for
the player or for the for the player on
the day of the game like i've never
really heard that before mike that's a
new one to me so that shows me that
antonio knew on sunday whoa i've gone
awol for three days i need someone to
call and smooth this thing over for me a
little bit before i walk in the stadium
that's what i found interesting
think about how other coaches would have
reacted to getting a call from a
player's agent on game day what would
bill belichick have done i don't think
he even would have taken the call right
i agree what are you doing calling me on
behalf of your player on game day it's
game day he needs to get his butt in
here and he should have had his butt in
here each of the last three days now i
still have an issue with your belief
that the steelers are going to sit him
down and say
you've crossed the line yeah you've got
to get right and if you do it again
there's going to be consequences i think
they've already had that conversation
with antonio brown that's what makes
this such a problem because this isn't
the first time he's crossed the line i
think he decided based upon warnings
he's gotten in the past if i'm gonna
cross the line this time i'm gonna make
it count because they've told me they've
warned me they've counseled me they've
they've made sure that i know exactly
where i stand and exactly what the
consequences will be so i think that
that the conversation you're suggesting
remember we tried to play it out
yesterday but you wouldn't do it because
you knew you were going to lose that
back and forth i think that conversation
has already happened and i think now the
only question is how do they disengage
from antonio brown in a way that
preserves some semblance of trade
leverage like if you come out and say
we're going to trade this guy then
good luck getting full value for him but
i i think that they're at a point where
it's going to be very hard to rebuild
this bridge especially because i don't
think he wants to that's the key right
if you're going to sit down with a guy
and say you know you really better shape
up or ship out and he says i'll choose
ship out what do you do at that point
well i mean they can hold him hostage
you know like you've said they've paid
him money okay and then fine you want to
sit out and miss game checks or do
anything like that then there's going to
be issues there and then they can ask
for you know some of the signing bonus
that he signed early on they could ask
for portions of that back they can make
it ugly and to your point
like what you're saying like yeah i
understand i i agree there's probably
been sit-down conversations with antonio
brown talking about you got to stop this
you got to shape up behavior you know he
is respected in that building because he
is a worker and i've been there to
witness it during training camp i mean
he's out there running cones before
anybody else ready to go full go but at
the same time i don't think they've ever
really given them the ultimatum that
would just be my two cents there where
they've actually said like
like we haven't seen them suspended by
the team really we've seen them sent
home but we've never really seen a
hardline stance by the steelers they've
kind of always said we had a talk we got
something straightened out i think this
is the year where they're finally going
to say you know shape up or we're going
to start suspending you and we're going
to start saying it's conduct detrimental
to the team and they might try to ask
for money back and play that type type
of hardball
and and this is what we could see we
could see 2005 terrell owens all over
again where if they're not going to
trade him if they're not going to
release him then he's going to be
disruptive now i think with terrell
owens he took it too far he was too
disruptive there's a way to just show up
and do the bare minimum it's the hold in
not the hold out where you're there but
you're not really there you're there but
you're not engaged you're there you're
present you show up on time but you're
not really paying attention you're not
really as involved and as active you're
not working as hard as you did yeah not
100 percent invested right right would
his ego allow him to do that though
chris because he understands the
connection between putting in the work
and also going out on the field and
having big performances would he
willingly undermine his own ability to
go out and have big games i don't think
he would do that i don't think he would
either i agree i mean he might give
everybody in the building the cold
shoulder and tell them to you know f off
for lack of a better phrase every now
and then uh but i agree with you i think
in his dna it's about i'm gonna put in
work and when the lights come on i'm to
show you what i did to put in that work
and show you everything that i you know
has come out of it and i do think he's a
performer that way that'll be tough on
him and you know again i do think this
relationship can be mended uh i do
because first of all i don't think
antonio brown is you know totally crazy
okay i'll say you know he's he's a
little bit of a loose cannon but i'm not
gonna say he's crazy i think he's a
pretty smart guy to know wait i'm with
the pittsburgh steelers we win every
year i have one of the all-time great
quarterbacks throwing me the ball it
works out in a lot of positive ways and
again i am going to put my faith in a
guy like mike tomlin and i know i sound
biased but yes i'm biased because i
believe it and i've been around the guy
before to know what kind of communicator
is we had some personalities on our
tampa bay buccaneers defense you know
after they had won that super bowl it
wasn't easy to handle but man mike
tomlin was one of the lead lead you know
lead leaders as far as in our coaching
staff and the ability to communicate
with the warren sapps and the rendez
barbers and the derrick brooks and i do
have faith that he'll be able to kind of
get that going or at least mend it mike
you you don't sound biased you are
very few admit it let's do this though
mike you mentioned mike tomlin mike
tomlin did meet with the media yesterday
let's play a little bit of what he had
to say he was asked the specific
question of whether mike tomlin believes
that ultimately at the end of the day
antonio brown quit on the team here's
what tomlin said
you know you can describe it in whatever
ways you want to describe it but there
was a lack of communication there that
can lead to thoughts and things of that
nature that can go in many directions
the bottom line is that we're playing a
significant game
and he didn't do a good enough job of
communicating or being available
in the hours leading up to that
performance so we needed to make
decisions decisions pertinent to getting
prepared to play in that performance so
i've been really clear about outlining
what transpired the level of
communication and things of that nature
so obviously there's some things within
that that you can infer certainly
yeah that is a very
diplomatic way of saying antonio brown
quit on the team pretty much what
when when you tell the guy on friday go
get an mri and you know let's see how it
goes and you don't hear from him again
after that until sunday morning when his
agent calls and says he's good to go
that's the guy who's quit on the team
now the question becomes what will the
steelers do you think that they're going
to have this this final ultimatum type
meeting and maybe they'll suspend him
and find him going forward and be more
aggressive with him right one
possibility would be to just trade him
and be done with the distractions now
mike tomlin addressed that possibility
of antonio brown being traded
i'm not going to speculate
on trades and things of that nature
we haven't formally received a request
in that regard
so i'm not going to speculate i'm not
going to speculate in terms of where the
discipline might go and things of that
nature just know
that it's going to be addressed and it
will be addressed and needs to be
addressed
for obvious reasons
you hear them say they haven't received
a formal request you hear that you know
what that means that means no that means
that means that they're thinking about
it or something yeah they're waiting for
it it means
it means they've received an informal
request right they just haven't gotten
the letter on antonio brown letterhead
with the signature at the bottom they
know the guy wants out and it's been
reported that he wants out and see
that's where this thing potentially goes
off the rail for the steelers and they
have to ask themselves do we want to
engage
after a full year of le'veon bell
distraction do we want to have another
situation like this or do we just take
what we can get and move on and and this
is an attractive contract to trade for
chris because the way it was structured
they've paid him 33 million plus over
the first two years what is left for the
final three years is 38.9 million it's
under 13 million a year for antonio
brown for three years and none of it's
guaranteed so
if you're a team out there and you like
like yeah but what about you know the
raid what about your guy john gruden
would he roll the dice on an antonio
brown would he do well in that offense
yes fully motivated fully focused maybe
he would right no i do i think there's a
lot of teams out there you know that
some of the teams that are at the bottom
of the draft are at the top of the draft
as we would say now uh you look at the
top five picks or top six picks you look
at it and you go well there's some teams
that could certainly use some weapons on
the offensive side of the ball and have
deficiencies whether that's the jets the
cardinals the 49ers the raiders we can
go down the list it's pretty
unbelievable actually so i do think
there would be a market and that's what
they're going to have to do at some
point they're going to have to sit down
when you know calmer heads prevail here
in a few weeks and sit down with him and
see exactly where he is at right he
antonio brown is obviously mad flustered
feels disrespected a little bit by the
steelers uh i don't really understand
that and if it's just because of the
wednesday walk through and the fact that
they made him redo a play where he kind
of messed up and that's the story i've
been told then that's ridiculous but
regardless they are going to have to get
a feel for where he's at in this
situation is it salvageable because if
you do trade them and you lose 21
million dollars in dead money that's a
huge blow to your football team and also
you want to keep them because you're on
the cusp of still a super bowl window
and you have a quarterback that's at the
end of this career and you like it no
you're not you're not you're not on the
cusp of a super bowl window why because
we have seen they could have gotten a
super bowl this year they have and they
didn't you know why because it's not
about the talent it's about the way the
team is managed about the way the team
is running i'm sick about hearing how
great the steelers are when they go out
and under achieve every year and they
underachieve because tomlin doesn't have
control of that team and he better get
control of that team or he's going to be
gone after this year yeah yeah i said it
okay you said it wait i mean they
underachieved by being what the two seed
in the afc place
you're chief oh and what happened the
jaguars came in and kicked their ass all
over the place
on tomlin and tomlin knows it you can
this was the overlooked part of what
happened on wednesday right tomlin knows
he's got to make changes and tomlin
knows if he doesn't it's his butt on the
line going forward and it's about time
he realizes it there's a there's a flaw
in his coaching style whether it's
situational football whether it's
properly ensuring that these guys it's
one thing to get everyone's you know
personality on the same page and and get
these guys all working together it's
another thing to hold people accountable
when they need to be held accountable
and he hasn't held a b accountable and
he needs to hold him and others
accountable now or this is going to be
on him because when you have that talent
if you have a coach that isn't getting
the most out of it at some point you're
mike mccarthy chris well okay but you
know he's been to two super bowls he's
won one of them they're in the playoffs
almost every year they're one of the
same thing is same thing as mike
mclaughlin okay
but if you chronically under achieve
sooner or later you're gone we gotta go
okay all right but i don't like how you
give him all the blood later he didn't
draft him he didn't sign up to the
long-term deal there's a gm there
talented he's not that he doesn't do all
that but we'll talk about that later get
to commercial we'll talk about it we'll
talk about late
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports